face à la pression de 500 signataires
victime était plus allegri ottawa a
tranché pas de financement sans une
adhésion au nouveau bureau du
commissaire à l'intégrité du sport le
directeur général de la fédération est
un immense soutien de prose avoir été
informé des intentions de la ministre
des sports pascal saintonge lorsqu'il
s'est entretenu avec elle la semaine
dernière sinon une fourmi à
tous
le directeur général de bolat les droits
qui y voit un pas dans la bonne
direction il estime aussi que les
athlètes méritent une meilleure
protection leur colère s'est accentué à
la suite d'une récente agression
sexuelle alléguée à l'endroit d'une
fillette de 7 ans par un entraîneur d'un
club de lethbridge en alberta
les gymnastes exige la création d'une
instance indépendante de traitement des
plaintes les primordial de protéger nos
athlètes le cabinet de la ministre
saintonge affirme qu'une invitation pour
une rencontre avec gymnastes pour le
changement a été décliné en avril
aujourd'hui à l'île du prince édouard le
premier ministre justin trudeau a
réitéré l'importance d'un milieu sport
sécuritaire pour tous les jeunes
sportifs canadiens david
kipping jean françois chabaud radio
canada montréal